pues últimamente hemos estado hablando
mucho acerca de variables aleatorias las
hemos definido de muchas formas y hemos
visto algunos ejemplos y bueno uno de
los que más he utilizado es uno que
proviene de volados se acuerdan de él
que le asignábamos 0 si salía sol y le
asignábamos 1 si salía a hielo
ahora lo único que no nos está diciendo
esta definición de la variable aleatoria
es con qué probabilidad sale sol y con
qué probabilidad sale águila o bueno con
qué probabilidad la variable x toma el
valor de 0 o de 1 y bueno para obtener
esa información lo que necesitamos es la
función de distribución de la
probabilidad aunque ya ver déjame
escribo es el nombre
acción
de distribución
distribuye
débil
das
y esta es una variable aleatoria
continua o discreta pues estos
resultados los del resultado del
experimento o sea los valores que puede
tomar x son distintos los puedes
enumerar los puedes contar osea así está
definitivamente es una variable
aleatoria discreta y entonces lo que
vamos a estar viendo es una función de
distribución de probabilidad
discreta
supongamos que alguien llega y te dice
ok he definido esta variable aleatoria
para cierta moneda que yo tengo y te voy
a dar la función de distribución ok
entonces bueno generalmente las
funciones de distribución de variables
son letras discretas son muy fáciles de
dibujar y osea con el dibujo puedes
saber exactamente cuál es la función de
distribución pero bueno entonces saber
en el eje de las x vamos a poner todos
los valores que puede tomar x en este
caso es 0 1
queremos poner valor cero y el valor 1 y
en este eje vamos a poner las
probabilidades con los que los puede
tomar no saben que voy a empezar por la
función de la densidad de probabilidad
ok vamos a borrar esto entonces vamos a
ver la función
densidad ok o sea estamos muy
interesados en la distribución de
probabilidad de la variable aleatoria x
para ver eso pues vamos a utilizar la
función de densidad de probabilidad
ok la probabilidad
con la que x toma estos valores bueno
aquí pudimos haber puesto muchos otros
valores y después poner que la
probabilidad de que x los tome es 0 pero
vamos a dejarlo así entonces llega esta
persona y te dice que la probabilidad
que x tome el valor 0 es del 50% o sea
la probabilidad que su moneda caiga en
sol es del 50%
ok y esto también se puede escribir como
punto 5
la probabilidad de que la variable actor
ya tome el valor 1 es del 60% o sea
bueno eso también se puede escribir como
punto 6
y mi pregunta para ti es bueno yo sé que
apenas estás empezando a aprender acerca
de funciones de distribución de
probabilidad y de variables aleatorias
pero con lo que sabes ya de probabilidad
mi pregunta para ti es si esta es
realmente una función de densidad de
probabilidad bueno pensemos en cuál es
la probabilidad de que x tome alguno de
los valores que puede tomar
entonces vamos a ver cuál es la
probabilidad de qué
x igual a cero estamos haciendo aquí una
unión o x sea igual a 1
probabilidad que x sea igual a 0 es como
aquí nos dicen es punto 5
y como son eventos these juntos o sea o
x 0 x 1 entonces aquí podemos sumar las
estas dos probabilidades y la
probabilidad de que x sea igual a 1 es
punto 6 ok y entonces nos queda 1.1
estos eventos son difuntos porque en su
intersección no hay nada y esta es la
probabilidad de que x tome cualquiera de
los valores que puede tomar o sea no
puede tomar ningún otro valor y está muy
extraño que haya sumado 1.1 de lo que
nos está diciendo es que tiene 110 por
ciento de probabilidad de tomar
cualquiera de los valores que toma pero
pues o sea eso no tiene sentido porque
si nos fijamos en las probabilidades de
que x tome cualquiera de los valores y
las sumamos eso nos tiene que da el 100%
de la probabilidad entonces esto
definitivamente está mal o sea la
probabilidad de que x tome cualquiera de
los valores que puede tomar eso tiene
una probabilidad de 100 por ciento ok y
esto es mayor que el 100% toda la
probabilidad o sea esto definitivamente
no puede ser así entonces vas con la
persona que dibujo esta función de
densidad de probabilidad y le dices le
explicas esto o sea que la suma de estas
probabilidades tiene que ser menor o
igual que el 100% y tenéis
ay si me equivoqué me equivoqué me
equivoqué esto no era el 50 por ciento
la probabilidad aquí en realidad lo que
tenía era un 40 por ciento de
probabilidad o sea 1.4
y te vuelve a preguntar si está ahora si
ya se ve como una función de densidad de
probabilidad de una variable aleatoria y
pues mira o sea las probabilidades con
las que x toma cada uno de los valores
que puede tomar ahora si suman 1 no se
apuntó 4.6 ahora sí ya es igual a 1
entonces sí ya puede ser una función de
densidad de probabilidad y ahora te voy
a preguntar qué es más probable que
salga águila o sol tirando esa moneda
que está siendo modelada por esta
variable aleatoria y pues bueno o sea
estable aleatoria tiene una mayor
probabilidad de que salga el 1 cierto o
sea tiene puntos 6 de probabilidad de
que salga uno ya x le asignábamos 1
cuando salía águila en la moneda aunque
entonces ésta es lo que representa la
probabilidad de que salga águila con la
moneda a la que x está modelando
entonces no es una moneda justa es una
moneda cargada hacia las águilas bueno
vamos a parar este vídeo aquí pero en
los próximos vídeos vamos a estudiar más
de estas funciones de ansiedad de
probabilidad
bueno la distribución de las variables
aleatorias en realidad o sea es el
centro de la probabilidad y van a ver
cómo son muy útiles cuando empezamos a
estudiar estadística inferencial